[Music]
in triggered news submitted by your from
Wong foo right yeah
a woman attacked a man on the street
with her breasts after she allegedly
caught him staring that is awesome with
her breasts
that's height how do you assault someone
with a deadly titty Wow I have a
question yeah let's watch the video
first yeah [ __ ] cares yeah alright so
this video takes place in Southeast
Brazil
Oh Brazil those are some big boobies it
was this young cells woman who had been
handing out flyers Oh heading out
titties and then finally like that was
just this one guy that I was like blast
draw cuz then she ends up attacking him
and then she's gonna be yelling things
so Portuguese tell you now is she's
yelling okay so at one point she says
she's fed up of being touched and
sexually harassed while doing her job
touched yeah the man is pleading her to
stop cuz she's attacking him and he's
saying that he was just out shopping
with his wife and he has done nothing
wrong
and there was other people around
shouting like this is absurd there's no
justification for this how can you do
this in front of children in the city
centre you're disrespecting women with
your actions so that's what was that in
the video so let's watch it think she
snapped let's see it assault with a
deadly today he didn't Oh was it work I
guess she's wearing a logo or something
like you're looking at big what you want
Wow that's awesome
if that guy's into that kind of stuff I
could see that Adam as having a good
time as well all those guys that like to
get their ass beat and choked out in
front of his life
okay and where did the titties attack
him cuz oh there was she slapping his
face she helped him motorboat her yeah
how did he even get him to the ground
she was he said he was just the last
straw out of all the ones that day he
just caught the last one man yeah like
that sucks because maybe he was the one
that just went like this and then it was
just game over
imagine how much unwanted attention she
gets for her to flip out like that she
wasn't scantily clad at either it was
like she's wearing a t-shirt yeah I
wasn't like you know as a dresser yeah I
was picturing like one of those girls
that are like hey you want to come to
the club tonight and they're wearing
like a nurse's outfit or something yeah
cuz you know like even like that like
the hottest [ __ ] girl like a sexy
nurse I guess you're like he's hot maybe
a hot girl but if she wears one of those
volunteer t-shirts normal you don't get
it just because you're like the hot girl
you just get it because you're a female
like this whole people hit on you it's
not specifically like what do I mean
like a Latin catcalling cool yeah yeah
like it doesn't matter if you're like
stereotypically hot or not it's just you
could just just because you're a woman
like you're getting the [ __ ] reek of
pheromones so it's like a pretty good
ego trip to be in a Latin country let's
say if you're like a three here in the
US for you maybe but if you did it a lot
its harassing or like if you get a zero
in the u.s. right and then like when you
go to Mexico and someone's like
I guess so it's an ego booster then I
guess it's kind of like this it's like
if you've never been hit on before yeah
just go to Mexico and then get sick of
it and then you won't mind it when you
can I wouldn't mind it
you'll always mind it know you're
getting that head-on and not getting hit
on this one I'm saying then you'll just
be like I'm so over it now you know I
mean I'm constable dude I'm talking
about the girls that wanna ego boost and
then they go it's a gas that lets go to
the club but you know they really going
for like compliments and like guys
wanting them and then don't maybe hear
what my girlfriend's got away and then
they go you see all those guys trying to
get out us yeah I have a question do you
yeah do you feel as if this is just an
opening a question I have no emotions
our ties to this question at all do you
feel like let's say you write you're
walking outside you're like you know
what today I'm gonna where the [ __ ]
where my titties are like guys are like
like do you feel like it's wrong with
them to look no I mean I feel like it's
natural even I look at girls that's it
sometimes sometimes it's just like right
there you're like oh [ __ ] so I don't
blame them but the part when I get angry
that's when they actually like catcall
treat you like a sex object it's like
what the [ __ ] do what if they're staring
is that the same as catcalling now
there's a difference what's your
definition of stare cuz the way I've at
least got in the stairs and I'm sure you
can agree with this it's like this very
uncommon dressing you it's like on the
cusp of like I'm about to pounce on you
and rape you because like you know what
they were saying is like if you wear
something low-cut right and then you
don't blame anyone because guys and
girls we're both like look or whatever
but let's say the guys just looking like
how long is it a long lengthy or is it
like how intense it is like what what
determines or what separates a look from
a stare see that they're at least trying
to be respectful cuz if they're just
staring at me like I don't give a [ __ ]
how you feel oh that's what that is see
a clip ahead I think to get into the
guys mind sometimes they zone out
you see the guy look at a [ __ ] nice
car drive by that's okay
yeah it would say that's still okay if
the part where like I'm moving or I'm
readjusting and he's like this feel like
yeah well like he's trying to x-ray
through your clothes and [ __ ] and then
make noises and then like make comments
and you're just like what what's the
noise like oh that should be the
universe okay calm down yeah like like
they see like a juicy piece of steak and
you're just like whoa what the [ __ ] I
mentioned it before there was a really
really really really really really
attractive woman
but everybody in the JIT like I
literally went to go work out and then I
saw her and I went back to look at her
again cuz I couldn't believe she existed
as a human being you know everybody
stopped like just what the [ __ ] is this
and clearly she wasn't from the states
because she was just at a 24 hour and
this very like skin-tight like baby I
was like this is not the place for you
to do this this late at night
because there we were just like so
confused we couldn't figure it out like
who is this goddess yeah there's a
difference between I just like like
dumbfounded stare you're just like oh
[ __ ] like that like what you're talking
about it okay it's borderline rapey yes
super raping you with this but words and
I yeah it's very uncomfortable I'm gonna
say some dirty things and there's
nothing you can do about it be like this
like you could be like dressed like this
and just because they can tell you're
like a female they're just like [ __ ]
staring you down and you're like how
like my sister was pregnant you guys
have seen this is where my sister was
practice like she would still get that
[ __ ] I'm like what and this is for the
most part yeah see I don't think I've
hung around with the group of Mexican
girls out on the streets to know what
this feels like well I'm not saying it's
just Mexican again I mean I'm not saying
it's just Mexican either vibes I did
walk home with one of my friends she was
of the Mexican nature and sure she was
developed in the in this in high school
and then instead of taking the bus we
decided to walk and on the way there
there was a guy there was a bunch of
guys the lawn mowers in their pickup
truck and they did
dude she's like [ __ ] [ __ ] and I
was like thinking you guys are old I saw
it once so this whole video thing here
later on it was discovered that this was
a stunt staged by a theater crew
confluency odd group and they did this
as an attempt to draw attention to the
harassment and awkward sexual attention
that women often face they said this
quality cool yeah the group's director
said we wanted to expose and address
something that happens everyday to our
sisters and female friends this was
meant to challenge people's perceptions
and empower women with this shock tactic
of retaliation we wanted to force men to
think more responsibly about their
actions and the consequences
I want experience like that one day cuz
I do guys do this in front of other guys
yeah it's in front of it doesn't matter
you've done it in front of my dad my mom
had to check like recently - she was
just like hey don't do that [ __ ] that's
my [ __ ] daughter like I respect and
I'm like oh mom thank you so what do to
a Hispanic man in Spanish all of them
yes that's [ __ ] tight what do mechs
can men do like if let's say you're with
your brother or like you with your dad
and you guys are walking around and then
there's a guy that right what's the
cultural normal response is it hey
there's my daughter [ __ ] you wanna
[ __ ] fight men too man or is it kind
of like I'm used to it from a man or is
it came from these no it's more of like
I don't I'm surprised he did it in front
of your dad actually you know once a
friend my dad the other time like we'd
pass by and then they wouldn't like
they've realized that he was with me and
they would think so what did your dad do
yeah because it's how much she's more
that you usually it's it doesn't happen
if you're in front of a dad yeah that's
how my dad reacted he ended up bringing
me closer and you're just the hands up
like saying some [ __ ] to them and then
we kept walking mm-hmm I know it's not
only Mexican guys to like I've had cat
calls were like other races all the time
like when I was younger and not the
Cambodians
Brackins we can't calm though by my
parents door all the goddamn time man
it's mainly me my guys that I had that
wasn't Mexican or Latino then it'd be
black guys but I mean and I was little I
was like in school I'm like you're gonna
pedophile do like you can clearly see
I'm not even of age at all I'm not even
a teenager yet but I remember though
like I mention this in a video before
I've seen the war it work and I think
it's that minimal amount of success that
cuz there was beef somewhere the cat
Kali Osama what's she doing now were you
from whatever what not right and she'll
be a [ __ ] you whatever they walk off and
I [ __ ] you too [ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ]
about your West anyways right but then
there's that's like one would you say
what's up on what you feel like there's
some sort of persuasion and because it's
not like pepper like is there a certain
level of hotness that the guy can
possess that would make the cow know
you're [ __ ] creepy as [ __ ] if you
come up to any girl real so if Channing
Tatum came out decrease like the
negative beneath the woman when you do
that right it's not a man that's like I
could have you if I want that's hot mmm
is that like there's no confidence you
know it's blowing over how hot you are
and he could never get you it's the
thirstiness that comes off our steen and
I've ever been hugged by a guy friend
that smelled you tighter so you could
feel my boom that dad a lot I only much
I remember this dude hugged one of our
home girls from behind and I literally
heard him smell her not even a friend
that's a rapist yes we've all been
friends in that group and this fell out
of nowhere just for some reason that day
hunger
hey it's like oh so I can creep I don't
think you're supposed to do that
brilliant off at least be like oh you
smell nice today not be like yeah it was
like one of the but she did that you
know that you know me like we playing
hard to get
[Music]
[Music]